there was a hunter in the VC legend no  matter who or what he is he's after our  bounty make sure this is the right one  it's her good  game-wise I made a hope  it sees to know what in the hell is  going on I think when you fight have  stumbled into a war with some of the  most powerful dynasties in the universe  you are royalty your majesty you are in  for a surprise when you find out what I  do for a living first know what you do  so you want  Majesty's life is going to change I help  me  your earth is a very small part of a  very large industry  right now by them I was entitled to that  once you claim it yes what belong to you  I will harvest that planet tomorrow  before I let her take it from we need a  plan and we need firepower  thank you  you've been searching for one thing your  whole life that she's down there  you should have stayed